hello everyone and uh thank you for
joining this uh session
uh i am jeremy tulu and uh i'm a
software engineer at uh kronstack and
also a core jupiter developer and today
i'm joined with
barter maduro and dustin who are also
working at the construct and
maybe we can just introduce ourselves
when we have
the screen so we have a smooth uh
transition so
uh i'm going to start uh by
um
presenting what we are what we have here
so we're going to demo
a new project called uh jupiter light
which is a jupiter distribution powered
by a web assembly and
the
the thing about jupiter lights is that
everything
runs in a in the browser so
you can check it out on github
this url right here
and
and yeah and you can also play with it
but maybe you can have a look at it
after the talk so
here we're talking about
browser-based interactive computing and
data science so
what you can do here is that
we have a python kernel called biolite
and we can just start and execute code
so it behaves just like
a normal python kernel you would be
using in a traditional jupiter lab or
jupiter classic
notebook
but the difference here is that
everything is running in the browser so
this idea of having everything
self-contained in the browser is or not
new actually so there is a little bit of
history uh about this uh
for example this drive project that was
started by
uh nicholas bolbeck who contributed a
lot to uh the jupiter light project
uh is uh also an exploration of how to
run everything uh in a browser so here
we have a screenshot of a kernel using
uh the python interpreter uh running a
browser so i think if you hit that url
maybe it will just uh still work i
believe it's still up and running uh on
on github pages so
uh yeah it's it's quite nice actually um
then there was also this other project
that i started maybe more than a year
ago uh but it was more focused on a
p5.js minimal ui for
writing sketches in a notebook
and this one was
taking a different approach by
taking all of the jupyter lab components
and building something from scratch
while the jive approach was more about
taking jupiter lab and then trying to
make it work in a browser by
patching things so that they work so
most like a top down approach here
bottom up
here
and uh it's also worth noting that there
are other projects uh
one of them is called baston that is
made by
horma kazati which is also
about using python in the browser
and this one is uh actually based on the
classic notebook ui
there are also other projects not
directly related to jupiter uh starboard
is uh the well polished and
kind of has this modern look
where you can use notebooks uh in a
browser so it could be for javascript
python but other languages and there is
also observable uh which takes a
different approach uh it's more based on
the reactive programming and it's very
also very interesting to uh
to uh to have a look at those uh as well
so here we're talking about uh jupiter
light uh which is a combination of these
two interfaces so jupiter lab and retro
lab
that you can use in your browser so
there are a couple of features
that are supported by jupiter lite
um so here if you open the file browser
you have access to
a
couple of files
and those are notebooks uh so actually
you have
uh something that behaves almost like a
real file system so you can create a
folder
uh you can go in a folder and then if
you want you can create a new notebook
here and it will be saved in your local
storage
in your browser and there are also other
files that come from a server so those
are actually pre-populated
and
they actually served over a you know
plain http server
so the combination of the two are kind
of merged so it gives you this kind of
smooth and
seamless
interaction with files
so if you change something in the
in the interface it's also saved to the
browser storage so for example here we
have a support for themes so you can
have
the dark theme
um or you can go back to light there is
also this one which is quite uh
quite nice and funky it gives you more
like this kind of flashy effects so all
of these are actually normal jupiter
lab extensions but they also work in
light uh so that's great and if you
change the theme and refresh the the
page uh the theme will be persisted so
your preferences will be persisted
we also have support for multiple
uh
kernels uh running on the page at the
same time so here we have this
javascript kernel that we started uh
earlier but if we open this one then we
see that uh they show up here and we can
switch between them by clicking on that
uh
item here in but we can also
shut them down uh if we don't use them
so so it also behaves pretty much like a
normal or jupiter lab
and then there are a couple of other
features like um installing a console uh
so you can have like a console like like
this
and then you could do uh something like
this so this one is running in
javascript
um also renders uh files
just like in a interpreter
lab so here you can open a csv file
um
you have also a json
for bigger light
charts
images
and also uh geojson files
so
yeah so pretty much what you would
expect
[Music]
and
finally we also have uh
support for retro lab like we mentioned
earlier so here you have this kind of
classic look
to your interface you can open
a notebook in a new tab and it gives you
this
document-oriented ui and then we can
change the language like this
if we want there's also support for
display languages so here i'm switching
the interface to french so we see the
menus
are in french and this is saved also in
the preferences so if i refresh the page
here we have
uh all of the buttons in french
so i'm going to switch back to english
and go back to here
yeah so that's um that was a little tour
of what you can do with light
like one you know one very nice aspect
for this is that it really boots uh very
quickly so
if you go to this repose we are actually
using this uh
repo here this uh
demo repo for the talk and if you click
on this
it opens a new tab and it puts uh really
quickly
so
yeah and
this is also by a bucket of pages so
yeah and you can also do it on read the
docs so the the nightly build we have on
the main uh jupiter light repo is uh
hosted on with the docks so more on the
on the hosting a little bit
later
okay so now we're going to cover some of
the features and i will leave it to uh
tomato
yeah
so
uh jupiter light is based on uh at the
pyrelite kernel and the pilot kennel
underneath is powered by pyrite which is
project by mozilla which compiles the
python scientific ecosystem to
webassembly and uh within that we have
also integrated the ipython the ipython
candle
so ipython is a powerful interactive
shell and comes with its own set of
features and combined usage of biodiet
and ipython
gives us the pilot kennel which has
a support for lots of features such as
redirected screens and error handling
and some of more which we'll see below
so you can see the version of the pilot
kennel here and you can of course
execute all the
simple code cells but since we have
ipython integrated we also have support
for redirected chains so all the
standard output and the standard errors
and since ipython is integrated we also
have support for beautiful error trace
packs here
and
uh
the support for code completion is also
there so if we press tab here
we see that the kernel here is busy
and it's you know working for us and we
we get all the options
um to complete our code with
we also have a code inspection so you
can let's say
inspect documentation about something
and maybe also access
the dot string in the types
next we also have
support for inputs but
but since uh
you know
python the pilot kennel uses promises
underneath to interact with uh the
kernel and the front end uh the await
keyword is used here so this is a caveat
by using paradigm
and
here it asks for a value let's say my
name is mother
and then we can access this variable
here
and pi python comes with the right
support for displays for all sorts of
mime types so
you have html you have
markdown you can display pandas
data frames
and execute a bit
so here is the pandas data frame
and then we also have uh more
capabilities of the display module so we
can clear some outputs update some
displays so here we have a screen a
square of let's say orange color and
we'll convert it to a square green color
[Music]
and here we have hello and after some
seconds it's gonna change to goodbye
and this is gonna prevent flickering
uh
so we already discussed about
the html but we can also write you know
mathematical expressions and even latex
in it
we also have support for progress bar
jsons
and in fact geojsons as well
we can also actually use network
requests and the fetch keyword is
actually the javascript api for fetching
requests but you can but since spidey
is compiled to webassembly webassembly
brings python and javascript to the same
level so you can call javascript apis
from python just like here
[Music]
and
you can use simpli to have mathematical
in
integral expressions and
since we have support for ipython it
also implicitly adds add supports for
magics so you can do all sorts of stuff
like all the magic commands you know ls
and print working directory
and write a file and also show your
history
um
we also have features on interactive
visualizations and ipi widgets and i'll
leave martin to present that next
okay
so as model showed you we
we did our best to provide all the
features that python provides
so
we also did our best to
to support the interactive
visualizations libraries like plotley
and dyer volume and matplotlib so i'm
going to show you this right now
so
when you spy you died and by your light
you get access to
this macro pip library which is actually
a kind of pip but
for pio died
and you can use it to install a package
like that so here i'm installing
properly
it will only work with the pure python
packages so probably the pure python
package it works but it will not work if
it's a
if it's a python library that depends on
a c extension and that needs to be
compiled
so now that this is installed um i
should be able to get a plotty plot
working
fully in the browser
so this is really cool
so that was flatly added yeah also works
if i show it to you quickly
so in order to install lda i need to
install
um the wheel to json schema
and this might be fixed
um in
in the next releases
so once this json schema is installed we
can install altair
and we should be able to use it
it's taking a bit of time to install
so yeah it's installed and it should
work
so that was spratley and altair and of
course we support matplotlib and this is
a given there is a
special case format partly because we
provide it by default just like we
provide numpy and pandas by default
so
it will use some kind of inline backend
it's not really the ipython inline
back-end for now
but it it will behave
a bit
closely
um using my micropeep you can actually
install the ipad mpl i can format cloud
libre
and then using the mattress
magic
from my python and passing the widget
argument
you can have an interactive
metal material plot inside
jupiter light
so you can resize
you can zoom
so this is a mpl i really suggest to
check it out it's cool
let me just
shut down the kernels
so
we also wanted to support jupiter
widgets of course because they are core
packages of jupiter
so for that we implemented the
communication there is between
python objects
in
in api widgets
and their javascript counterpart
so when i install it and create a slider
from python
i can interact with it i can get back
the value in python
i can set it to 5 for example
i can display it multiple times
it will be synced between the views
i can also sync multiple widgets
together
so here i am
i'm linking the
text widget to the slider
so yeah we have this back and forth
communication between the widget
the the javascript widget and the python
object
so because we support ipad widgets we
we should support for free most of the
widgets libraries um given that they
don't
uh depend on a c extension for example
so bq plot works big plot is a plotting
library based on ipad
you can create interactive plots
and because they are widgets
you can update those plots from python
dynamically
and it will react in the page
so for example here i get a line chart
i can change the line chart color
i can change its style
i can also make a bar chart and update
the data dynamically
with a nice animation
and this is all running in the in the
browser
another widgets library
that i worked on is i buy canvas so if i
canvas aims at
exposing the html 2d canvas api to
python
and this is really cool for learning
python because you
you with the canvas you can do drawings
you can draw whatever you want and it's
actually fun to play with
here i created a game of life example
so i'm drawing the grid and
with the for loop and
some sync io slip calls i can make an
animation of the canvas
okay i
guess i'm going to skip back belly flat
for now i mean but you can check check
it out um if you want
all those notebooks you can find them on
the demo um
repository that jeremy showed you
and i'm going to leave the board to
thorston who is going to show you uh how
we
expose the zeus kernels to egyptolite
hi
so um
first let me explain a bit what seuss is
so seuss is a c plus plus library for
writing jupiter kernels
it's not a kernel itself but it helps
you to write kernels like seuss cling
for c plus plus oxos python source lua
sql and many more
and we recently showed how to um how to
write jupiter light kernels for that
um
is really extendable so it has three
extension points the interpreter this is
basically the the interface you have to
implement if you write a new kernel
it focuses on simple message and follow
simple methods like execute the actual
code or complete the code
then there is debugger the debugger
interface which is optional if you want
to have debugging capabilities for your
kernel
and last but not least there is the
server
the server is
basically a middleware which is
responsible for sending and receiving
the messages from the client and in this
context the client is the jupiter server
so the server basically
also implements the concurrency um model
so basically which things are running
which thread
before we talk about source light let's
have a quick look how this normally
works with normal jupiter so you have
the kernel on the right side
and it communicates with its client the
jupiter server via zero and q
and in particular the kernel is also
running in a different process normally
than
than the front end and the jupiter
server but for jupiter light this looks
a bit different
so we end up with this kind of
architecture
so let me start on the right side so we
have the c plus plus code for source
cards and with webm script we can
compile this to webassembly and
javascript
the next thing we do is we put this web
assembly code and javascript code in a
web worker such that we can use it
without blocking the main thread
and then we have a tiny layer of
javascript or typescript code
implementing responsible for
implementing the jupiter light icon rp
and this communicates with message
passing with the vistagsu's kernel
yeah and in this way we can utilize soos
also for um
deriving jupiter light kernels
and the first kernel we started with um
was lua
kernel why lua lua is really really
simple to compile to web assembly so we
didn't expect any problems there and
this is where we started with that and
let me show how this works
so
here
i implemented a game of life similar to
the one in python but in pure lua it has
a lot of helper functions so we will
just run all cells
the cool thing about lua the whole
binary is really really small so it
loads more or less instantly and
what we end up with is here also by
including some widgets
um a game of life which does not look
that nice um because we don't yet have
support for the canvas so we're just
printing it but we soon will also add
the support for the canvas in lua
we not only have this example but also
a nice example with widget support so
when all the widgets can also be used
from this lure kernel so i'm going to
show a few so we have
we have sliders um
drop-down menus
like everything you want to have in the
widget library
and
yeah this can all be
used in the browser and is also part of
the jupiter light demo repo
then we
not only wanted to experiment with one
language but see if we can
easily integrate other languages or
other kernels into jupiter light
and we choose maybe not so well known
language it's called ren
it's a library you typically use if you
you want to embed in c or c plus plus
code and we choose this because it's
also really easy to compile to web
assembly and
we built a tiny package that you can
that you can use this for displaying
json data
like this or displaying latex data or
html or other meme types
yeah so
both of these kernels run in the browser
and start super super
fast and since they are so
since the web assembly binaries are
really small
and uh now i will give the word to
jeremy again
yeah thanks everyone for uh for these
cool demos so what you can do with um
uh right also is to share files with
someone else so if you
select multiple files and then a copy
shareable link you can send the link to
someone and when the drive will be
booting then it will open this files by
default so that is quite useful
especially
with real-time collaborations so if
you're interested in this you should
check out the talk by kevin uh which was
yesterday
but um the idea here is that uh this uh
all of the work that was put into triple
app can also be reused in jupiter light
with the difference that
we use a webrtc as the provider so
you should also check the documentation
on the drip delight to learn how to
enable this
and how to use it
a quick word on how all of this stuff
works so now that we
demoed a little bit like uh all of the
features
uh you might wonder like how does this
work so uh since everything runs in the
browser we still have uh
a need for some kind of server so here
on the left we have the lab and retro
lab interfaces but the thing is that
they connect to a
server that runs in the browser and by
that we override the fetch and the web
sockets that you find in the browser
usually so that they talk to a special
instance of the server and the server is
a lumino application which is using the
same uh plug-in system as what you have
in jupyter lab which is why we were able
to reuse almost all of the tooling
already in place for the lab to be able
to
add uh extra server extension searches
such as the the kernels we are we are
demoed uh earlier
so there is also a diagram on this on
the docs if you want to check it out
um use cases so of course the idea is to
have something that runs in a browser
without installing anything
and without having to deal with servers
uh it's really great for educational
purposes because then you can only focus
on the content and here we have some
kind of mockup where how this could
integrate with github directly so you
could edit
a notebook in place
there are also plans to have some
tooling to be able to easily
export your own website your website
include extensions themes and settings
so that is not done yet but
this is a just a mock-up
[Music]
with that you can create your own
distribution so the p5 book
project we talked about earlier uh
was actually uh redone recently to use
jupiter light and
and here you can customize it a little
bit so it's focused on one application
it's the same for ipro io
which is
kind of a custom light distribution as
well
and for the deployment stories uh we can
deploy it pretty much anywhere because
you only need a http server like a plain
http server so it could be on github
pages gitlab pages
read the docs or other like more
front-end
oriented hosts such as a personal netify
and there is a documentation for how to
deploy your website
here
up next
there will be improvements to the
tooling to
rtc there will be more space kernels
we also try to improve the web assembly
story and try to reuse the uh ponderfort
um
tooling to be able to make that um
easy easier to use and uh there is also
ongoing work to you know make more
interactive documentation
uh for example with the tools like thebe
uh jupiter book and curve note
uh vs code.dev was announced recently
and the the vs code the pyrolyte
extension is actually using the pyrolyte
kernel with emotes so there are also
some interesting things we can do here
so that it works with the vs code
later we might be able to reduce some
load on the things like mybinder.org so
that the people can
start their notebooks in the browser
instead
and finally we will try to make wala
work also in a browser so you could uh
you know create and publish dashboards
uh without having to run a server so
um something to uh to watch uh for the
future
and with that i would like to thank
everybody who contributed to the project
and uh thank you for attending the
session thank you
it was a great talk and yeah i was i was
switching in between the talk and
moderating all the other things uh so we
do have a couple of questions
uh
let me let me start with the first one
yeah so the so christian asks are you
going to describe your build pipeline
uh i'm not sure if you went through this
so we we actually use pio died
uh directly in biolite so we don't
compile it ourselves on the python
uh interpreter but i guess you want to
say something more about it yeah yeah we
pretty much reuse bio diet as is uh
right now and it's fetched from the cdn
if you use the demo uh so it's really
just a stock pie diet uh one thing that
we mentioned at the very end was that we
might uh
look into making uh
the package management uh
a bit easier in the future so that uh we
can compose packages and create our own
custom uh biodie distribution more
easily with the
tools coming from the panda frog
ecosystem for example
awesome thank you
uh there's a question by david which
goes like i guess that there is no way
to interact with files from the
underlying file system one needs to
upload them directly to the jupyter
light directory yeah for now that's the
case uh we need to upload it and
download it but um there's an issue open
on the repo that we're going to
have a look soon is that we should be
able to also use the file system api
from the browser
so that you can mount a
local folder that is on your computer
into a jupyter lite so the problem with
this file system api is that it's not
supported on firefox so we didn't want
to have that in the beginning but i
think we can make it optional so that if
it's available then people can use it
that is you know in chrome
all right so i i have
time for only one more question so
yeah
is it jupiter light usable on a recent
model of ipad ipad yeah the absolutely
yeah as long as your ipad your browser
can uh
run web assembly which i think it is the
case on ipad uh and it should just
totally work and this is also
one advantage that you can also
run that on
low-end devices or devices that have
only you know access to web browser like
a chromebook also
so yeah
i would say it should work on the ipad
yeah
all right thank you
you